the origins of Santa Claus can be traced
back to an ancient urbanite demon named
San colosse who is said to visit homes
on the longest night of the year
devouring misbehaving children and
merely roughing up good children he was
said to travel from home to home on the
back of a giant flying creature made of
the assembled bodies of eight headless
goats and children would leave treats
for the demon to eat hoping to wake up
mostly unbruised Santa became less
terrifying in the fourth century as he
became associated with Saint Crangle of
mica Ned who had paid the dowry zuv
young women so they would not have to
become prostitutes it was actually
pretty easy to get cash out of crinkle
all you had to do was show up in heavy
eye shadow in heels and he throws some
coins your way after a while it became
easier for Kringle to just come to
everyone's house once a year and drop
off their annual don't be a hooker
payment st. kringle was eventually
combined with Yule daddy a holiday
character popular in England Ireland
Scotland Finland and Cleveland he was a
jolly fellow dressed in fur who came to
holiday celebrations drink the best Mead
invited women to sit on his lap bribe
children to go play somewhere else then
passed out by the woodpile it was
eventually discovered that it was
actually just one guy named Ernie who
got around a lot but by then the legend
of Santa Claus was born aspects of the
modern Santa Claus can be attributed to
different sources the poem a visit from
st. Nicholas established the names of
his reindeer and that upon his arrival
one should throw up the sash the
editorial cartoonist Thomas Nash
established Santa's fur coat and taught
the world that he lives in Tammany Hall
with boss tweed an inspector gadget
saves Christmas established that santa
needs a better agent Santa Claus
continues to evolve Sant ologist
speculated by the year 2100 Santa will
be a genetically engineered cyborg half
Yeti who can transform himself into a
pure data stream to deliver media
acquisition credits to the hollow
chambers of good boys and girls the
elves will be replaced with an elite
force of Arctic assassins fending off
attacks from the fire Lords however kids
will still leave milk and cookies some
things never change
change